let's talk about it all starts with the
writing so you know where did is he come
from um I good question you know it's
actually a character that I've been
dealing with for I'd say almost like 15
years
like just in it's not even like I've
been writing this group for that long it
was more like I just the my writing
process I come up with here I go talking
with the writing process right my write
come up the character and I'm so
character driven you know in almost like
an annoying place where I want like I'm
running a new thing now to where it's
like it's all it's a single lead
character and that everybody else is
supporting because I really believe in
first-person point of view moviemaking
so I'm always trying to who's a
character that's really interesting to
me and I just has had this image of this
girl in the back of a taxi cab in a
bloody white tux
and and I was like is that the end of
the movie is at the beginning of the
movie I don't know what it is but that's
a really interesting image to me and
then also then over time I just sort of
started to fill in the characters and
characteristics and backstory and all
that kind of stuff but that's just sort
of sort of where it came from
well McKenzie um obviously is he is so
many things I just she's just way more
complicated than just a riot girl so
when you read this script what what did
you like best about her what what made
you say yep this is me I want to do this
I I never know exactly what I like about
characters but I do like like I'm a very
different person around my especially
when I was younger like around my
parents versus how I was around my
friends or my teachers or whoever and I
felt like I've always really liked
characters that shifted who they were
the way that we all do - depending on
who their interlocutor was without it
feeling like phony or they were
manipulators and there were so many
opportunities for Izzy to shift her
identity in a way that's still totally
authentic to the person that she is
without it being feeling like she had
multiple personality disorder it felt
like a very organic expression of the
many selves that we have and I liked all
of the ones she
even the grading yes how did you
assemble this amazing cast soft shout
out to casting directors everywhere
because they work so hard and I don't
like they get enough credit so yeah two
things I mean one was McKenzie was
always our first choice and she we
didn't know each other she didn't know
us and and early on we've sort of put
this thing together we had I mean no
money which is like somebody's gonna ask
us at some point like okay woody mo how
much money do you have
we really had nothing and so we were we
were kind of going first thing we were
told to Mackenzie's not available so
we're like okay we'll go on down the
road and see what's going on some other
people that we like and and whatever and
and then all the sudden was like late in
the process it was October and we were
gonna shoot in January you know with the
big things were like we're gonna set a
start date because if we don't set a
start date then it becomes flexible and
everybody sort of disappears on you and
all those concepts were like we're gonna
set a start date we have them enough
money to shoot production so we're gonna
set a start date and we're gonna get
somebody to be the lead actor and
hopefully everything sort of flows
through there and and Mackenzie wasn't
available so we're going down the road
some other things and then also know
something then we kept watching halt and
catch fire and we were like well but
then you know all the sudden was like
hey listen she's available now and it
was like okay well great well let's send
it to her and see what happens and then
you know you can take from there then I
joined the cast but then I loved the the
script so much and asked if they'd let
me produce it with them because it was
something I was interested in being
involved with and and they graciously
let me join in for just the creative
heart and none of the hard stuff and and
then Chris and I just sort of went down
the list and talked about our favorite
actors and who we'd envisioned and we
kind of set the bar high and wrote
letters to you know all the people that
we really loved and really wanted to be
in the movie and for some reason like
almost all of them said yes Wow which is
so I mean it's wonderful and we're very
lucky but it also I mean it's the kind
of actor that all these people are that
they're willing to they like acting like
they like coming for a day and playing
around and it's really nice to work with
actors that like to come and just like
[ __ ] around for a day
and still have that sort of thrill of
like drama class in them hope we were in
LA and so people kind of just come for
day and it was like they would just you
know okay we're only asking two days I
mean the only person that was in with
with us more than two days was I think
Alex Russell
so as producer were you involved very
early on have you been sort of with this
project from its inception well Chris is
my husband so it was pretty [ __ ]
unavoidable but I'd say I was pregnant
with our our first son and we were
sitting by a pool and just talking about
wanting to make movies and not wanting
to wait but to just just do it you know
we were both antsy for something
creative to do I used to work in casting
and he was doing some other projects and
he had mentioned this woman in a bloody
tuxedo and I was like yes tell me
everything about that I think I know her
and and so as as he said I'm gonna just
do it I'm gonna write this script and I
think I was just I was still may be
working in casting right just quit
casting around that time and he wrote it
really quickly so from the first draft
or like notes ideas we discussed a lot
of the scenes so yeah it was fun to be a
part of that with him and then he said
you're already getting your hands in his
so much I really want you to produce it
with me and I said no that sounds
terrible that sounds terrible like we we
have a son together we live together
like I think there should be a line
drawn and then you know we were talking
about cast ideas and I'm giving him some
lists and then we're talking about
locations and I'm making phone calls
thinking you yeah and he's like actually
and then a good friend of mine said so
how's everything going I said good yeah
well and and you know Chris is doing
this movie and so I'm doing this and he
asked me to produce but I said no and
they were like well [ __ ] newsflash
you're producing it like now and I was
like you're right I should take credit
for that yeah so that so I said okay and
I'd like a contract
look at him writing Wow because if I'm
gonna produce and I'm gonna be [ __ ]
professional about I said so you guys
mentioned product location work so I
trying to remember I don't
is there any scene that wasn't shot on
location like you had money to do
something what I'm hearing is that the
budget for this film was what you took
from her drawer in that scene yeah yeah
you know this was shot in French houses
air beam bees and we got the really nice
house for the engagement
yeah the Los Feliz that was like a
really amazingly lucky thing that
happened to us that probably shouldn't
have but it did okay so it's not your
house no but it was really crazy place
at the top of this gigantic hill like
super dangerous to drive up there like
three o'clock in the morning but you
know people got up every survived which
was great believe in fate it was a lot
of fate because it was like holy [ __ ] we
lost the location we don't have a
[ __ ] location what are we gonna do
and then someone was like well I'm
selling my house you can trash it just
yeah don't break anything yeah and
you're like I'm like I don't think this
is a good idea
I don't want equipment in here like what
are we gonna do but it was we had a
bunch of luck we lost our first location
yeah before we were set to shoot they
were like newsflash they're gonna do
work on the water mains under my street
so the streets are all closed and
there's gonna be construction and whose
good friend of ours and he was really
broken up about it he was just like I
don't know what to tell you the city's
telling me how to do this thing so we're
just like you know it's just like one of
those things but you know whatever we
you know Megan just kind of worked your
magic and we powered through it well you
know I mean get out yeah maybe you
figured out and you don't have money but
you have people that really care about
what you're doing I mean a really simple
expense on pretty much any movie I mean
I'm talking like student film is a dolly
yeah have a dolly there's no dolly shots
in this there's no the camera never
moves there's a Steadicam shot at the
end of the movie whoo
we got a friend of ours to kind of give
us a favor we paid him a little bit of
money you know but it we got half a day
out of him and and but now there's no
that we had like a cameras on sticks I
mean it was like you know I wouldn't
even say like a 40s movie because they
had a dolly you know I mean so we didn't
have anything so it was either onto my
shoulder or his on sticks and that was
it I mean we just had to kind of make
that work whatever that was you know but
I'm very meticulous in my in my sort of
planning so if I know what my
limitations or I'll just work to that so
everything's storyboarding just to be
that sort of structured concept you know
things so worked out the way it did
thank you all for bringing Izzy to us
and sharing on with us